[Music]
you
so
hmm
okay so the first one
has a a
sort of setup okay but i'm not waiting
here he comes in
i'm not oh god no okay the the opening
is on the up so i have to read the up
okay now from
here in this training i've already taken
the
opening so as he's getting up yin yin
yin
you see don't use no i don't do another
one of those first reps
okay go go connection
yes
again okay
so again the first rep is like normal
keyhole
first round okay then after that
i stick to him here
[Music]
okay so uh when
straight in straight
straight in like your elbow
oh it's right there
[Music]
all right
so you can't you don't go this way i'm
on the line
it's ever so slightly my back foot is
over here you see
i clear the line boom
not straight this way that's going to
put you outside you see
it's outside outer deltoid okay the
front foot
is going to enter but the back foot is
going to
be
that's going to bring my elbow boom
right into it watch what happens if i
know it's off
okay this way
so up boom here
not straight in they're not still
inter-ed
me you change angle
bring your body don't leave your leg up
there
bye
see that way there's a yin opening for
the edema
if he's still coming this way until i
injure
let me do it if i could okay if i have
if that's when he finally goes that way
that's a yong yong clash
he's too big for me i can't do it i
can't do it okay
and you won't be able to do it for real
either okay so
the reconciliation is here
he's light over here i can move easily
into the free space okay
that's not what's taking him in the down
hole he goes walmart is done there's a
free space here
i'm just staying up with his elbow i
didn't push his elbow
i'm just staying up in his elbow
up he's already falling that way and i
feel that space and i stay up with his
elbow
boom
[Music]
okay